I have no objection to windfall taxes if  genuinely about windfall profits  caused by unexpected expect increases  Rises  but  but  I know the honor worm is obviously  getting excited at the talk of windfall  taxes can I just say that any such tax  should be temporary not to deter  Investments and recognize the cyclical  nature of energy businesses so taking  account of this  I've decided that from January the 1st  until March 28 we will increase the  energy profits Levy from 25 to 35  percent the structure of our energy  Market also creates windfall profits for  low carbon electricity generation so  from January the 1st we've decided to  introduce a new temporary 45 levy on  electricity generators